[Music]
hey what's going on and Happy Holidays
hot ones fans this is Sean Evans
checking in from the Museum of
curiosities we have a very exciting
holiday extravaganza for you today the
stocking full of questions a special
guest addressing the hot ones
controversies of season seven and
speaking of the build burnt wing number
nine controversy did he eat the wing
did he not eat the wing the answer is he
ate the wing to pull back the curtain on
the show one way in which we get super
clever in the editing is by speeding up
people eating if you just hear somebody
chomping on a wing for more than three
Mississippi it is an automatic vibe
killer and then sometimes it's a chaotic
scene and bill bird's wing aide is a
prime example he's fighting the bomb
he's taking laps all over the place and
afterwards the set was a mess we needed
to refill waters refilled milks swap in
new napkins and amidst all that chaos
bill start snacking on his number nine
wing we have a choice there we can keep
it all in untangle all the wires involve
stretch out this episode that's already
27 28 minutes long and put another 3-4
minutes on it but if it's not that big a
payoff then it's not worth doing because
in 2018 this internet age people have
the attention span of a gnat in order to
keep it streamlined in order to keep it
fast
we just lop it off sometimes another
topic that came up frequently and it
comes up frequently every year but I'm
happy to address it is Nipplegate
the nibblers they're nibbling now look I
am never going to be a chicken wing
referee the second that that happens is
the second that hot ones ceases to exist
but here I understand what you're saying
I want guests to commit to the wings at
least tried to go there whatever that
means for them but we're already putting
them in a pretty vulnerable situation
where they're eating spicy wings for the
Internet's amusement I think it would be
a super lame to hit him over the head
with all these House Rules right when
they walk in and then over the course of
the interview police them and wrist
slapped them because they're not eating
enough of the chicken wing
we have guests that are approaching 70
years old we have guests with medical
issues no one needs to kill themselves
eating chicken wings for the Internet's
amusement the only people you can really
get mad at are the ones who just walk so
if someone's not reacting not feeling
being like this is easy and they're
nibbling that to me is kind of lame but
if somebody is just dying in their
struggle city and they're taking smaller
bites that to me not a big deal even a
little bit all right now that we've
addressed the major complaints it is
time for your hard-hitting hot ones van
questions Chris Schoenberger bring me
the stocking of questions thank you very
much
and now we've reach into the stocking
and the first question comes from fill
me once asks what are some of your
favorite types of questions to ask after
all the research you do how do you
narrow the questions down to 10 well you
always like the questions that kind of
break the guests when they're taken
aback or delighted by a question or
wonder how you'd know it that's always a
good thing that means you cracked it on
some level and then when it comes to the
research what we do is we come up with
20 topics let's say over the course of
the research and then when we're
masterminding the interview we'll narrow
it down to 10 and you're always editing
that as you would go so it all just
depends on the guest it's always a
choose-your-own-adventure that kind of
shapes itself as the interview goes on
okay up next we have jean-philippe asks
what's the biggest misconception you
think people have about hot ones well I
think that as the show has grown people
think that it's some big machine that we
have a big staff like we don't it's the
same six or seven people that we had in
the beginning working through it now
people are like damn a team of
researchers they have writers no we
don't me and Chris have written every
run of show since the beginning and we
will do it till the end
we'll see this thing through exactly how
we want to see it and it's still the
small shop circus sideshow that it's
always been another misconception you
know people on the inner
always think people are high when
they're getting interviewed or they're
interviewing like dark they're high
they're definitely high or like they say
Shawn's hi listen I'll I'm forthcoming
about it I'm honest I like inedible I
like a vape I've talked about this many
times but you cannot run point guard on
an interview talk show high like this
show has not been done hive never been
high for an interview maybe my like my
look is just naturally sunken a little
bit people are eating scorching-hot
chicken wings maybe their eyes become
bloodshot at some point but people are
not high as much as people on the
internet think that the people who are
on shows are high like that's a
ridiculous thing and then another thing
is I think like every time a guy and
girl have been in an interview setting
it's always like they're definitely
boned people are always like they hooked
up oh yeah they hooked up that doesn't
happen either so I think that there's a
lot less sex in a lot less drugs in your
YouTube webseries than you might think
so those are the misconceptions joy joy
says can you tell the fans some fun
facts about the other members of your
team who help make hot ones every week
I'd be happy to bill behind the camera
you've gotten to know a little bit and
he's Laird he's an onion it's just
non-stop with that guy most interesting
man in the world
Dom producer Dom she is a friend's
obsessive when we're on the road she
watches 28 hours of friends Steven
Steven loves Arby's and gadgets he likes
little gadgets so that he can play with
lights and play with different things he
loves gadgets Sarah Honda hip-hop roots
go way back used to manage Gangstar and
mo pee I love that Chris Schoenberger is
obsessed with nachos in fact he used to
have a blog called nacho Hunter's
where him and his brother would travel
around trying to find the greatest
nachos in the world so that's a fun fact
and then our editor Colin used to put
together hot ones meme videos including
hot ones Tyra Banks but Sean's a serial
killer and now he's actually editing
the show so you can do anything if you
put your mind to it
mari she's a new mom she just had a baby
and remodeled her home and it looks
gorgeous
they're in upstate New York such a woods
cottage if I've ever seen one
Kristen Price big killing Eve fan will
not stop talking about that show I've
never watched a single second of it but
she's into it so check it out all right
up next have you consulted with a
physician to discuss the impact on your
health of eating really hot chicken way
too often well mr. Brown I appreciate
you checking in on me and you'll be
happy to know that I recently went to a
physician and I told them I need a full
report hook me up to everything get the
blood work I need to know everything
that's going on because in a very
prolific way I've been eating some of
the hottest chicken wings on planet
Earth Carolina Reapers the works over
the last three years and I might only
have six months to live so let's figure
this out I nervously await the test
results and guess what they come back
and I am smack dab in the middle of the
range on every single measurable I am
like an Olympic athlete with my health
perhaps these chicken wings are making
me stronger my doctor was on the phone
and they're like your vitamin DS a
little bit low but other than that these
are just spectacular numbers so I don't
know if it's hot ones to think I don't
know if I was just touched by the hand
of God but either way
season eight I'm ready for you and it
should be no problem well alright there
we are this stocking is empty but the
gifts on the hot ones holiday
extravaganza just keep on coming in
anticipation of tomorrow's Christmas Day
games on ESPN and ABC guys sat down with
an NBA legend to break down the game
film from some of our past MBA player
guests roll it
[Music]
welcome to the hot ones holiday set we
were joined by NBA countdowns Jalen Rose
you know I'm from his run with the Fab
five his storied 13-year career in the
NBA as well as getup and Jalen and
Jacoby on ESPN and we'll get into
tomorrow's games in just a second but
before we do I need the backstory on
your 1994 draft day fit because of the
holidays it is quite Christmasy
it is and so I had two suits that I was
able to go get one on was this lovely
red and white masterpiece that either
people think it's the best of all time
or the worst of all times but either way
I'm proud because it's Detroit well one
of the reasons we're really excited to
have you in the seat is because we need
an expert analyst to look at the tale of
the tape from some of the NBA players
we've had take on the wings of death and
we'll start with our most recent season
and Blake Griffin who had some
interesting thoughts and how the
Internet has impacted the slam dunk
contest so I'll just play the clip for
you and you tell me what you think okay
do you think it's harder to impress
people these days yeah a little bit but
it's also cool because like there's guys
that aren't in the NBA who maybe aren't
even playing overseas who are
unbelievable dunker so yeah you get to
see these like dunk highlights all the
time so yeah maybe the dunk contest is
taking a little bit of a hit but overall
in terms of like the the scope of Duncan
Zoomer mercy yeah exactly so it's great
for basketball it's great for the dunk
fan but maybe not the dunk contest I
don't think we've been desensitized to
it I think what has happened has become
too many props and it's too many missed
dunks and the other thing is the elite
superstar level players aren't
participating like I would have never
thought that LeBron James would play 16
years and never be in the dunk contest
so when that happens that takes a little
away from it as well I have another clip
for you as somebody who went from a
player and became a member of the sports
media press I'm curious what you think
about Kevin Durant's comments from his
hot ones interview
would you do differently as a member of
the sports price well I'm gonna be all
about the players and be all about the
players all about what they want to do
they're probably would a product we're
pushing the league the players are
pushing the league so it should always
be all about the players sorry that's
what you say but why you plan like once
you have a job and it is to analyze what
you see and have a colorful opinion
about it if a guy had a terrible game
with nine turnovers you can't be like oh
well we went to the same College you
know he's a great guy and you know
whatever you have to like will make you
good is to be able to articulate what
you see and in my opinion this is what I
try to do without name-calling and or
without making it personal which there
are a lot of media members that do that
and then you've covered the NBA for a
long time you're also a prolific
podcaster and here at hot ones we always
have our eyes out you know which player
would make an amazing guest who do you
think is the best interview in the NBA
right now I mean you've got the Masters
of the obvious like the LeBron James or
the world or Steph Curry type of elite
level players but I like elite level
players are also gonna be unfiltered
draymond Green comes to mind
Russell Westbrook comes to mind is guys
that do a really good job of balancing
being a player but also having a
personality with the media
all right well jaylen it's been a
pleasure I can't wait to put on my
sweats curl up and watch 12 consecutive
hours of basketball tomorrow any final
thoughts on tomorrow's games whatever
you saw me wearing on draft day I will
be a hundred percent more clean tomorrow
promise you
[Music]
well that's a wrap from the Museum of
curiosities thank you so much for tuning
in and Happy Holidays spice Lords we
really appreciate you rocking with us
through seven seasons 130 plus episodes
and beyond we're going to be very quick
on the off season starting up the hot
ones train in January so just opening up
some Christmas presents popping a hot
chocolate and then it's right back to
the studio
thank you for rockin with us through
season 1 season 2 season 3 season 4
season 5 season 6 season 7 and season 8
roll the montage ok what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter guests yeah sexy hot not like
temperately like sexual I've been
hearing on Twitter for so long when are
you gonna do hot ones how are you guys
the spicy food you cranked it up a
little bit I like a de spice I cranked
it well I'm nervous now I really think
about I'm getting myself into but never
had a house sauce in my life in your
entire life ever I'm excited I wanted to
do it
oh yeah pick a nap
oh just as long as it gets no hotter
than this Oh should be any issues
whatsoever Valentine I think milk is a
coward I think that's a cowardly move
then I think Isis wins can go from the
milk then the booty growing milk I know
I did all right I'm going milk I gotta
go back and the foodie revolution is an
honest trade gross it's room temperature
does that to somebody but just so I know
where is the post there's one in the
green room is it sound came up in this
place I was really really front but that
cheap right dad got me [ __ ] bug that
[ __ ] right there really for the public
Oh could you could you could you could
you could you good
[Music]
so mental it's that time boy wait a
second what do you why are you shaking
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because the tradition around here to
put a little extra on the last wing it's
the good strong healthy Cody but it's
optional right you don't have to if you
don't why would I want to oh I know that
talk you don't have to you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right cheers Cheers what a trip it's
been Pete what a wild trip it's been
[Music]
adapt the depth adapt
I'm the bike
I gotta walk it off yeah yeah go ahead I
gotta walk it off
take a lap though oh my god dude what's
the hottest [ __ ] thing I've ever ate
are you trying to pull it together
really really hard but it's not working
you found it deep in the nutsack on that
rocket sauce and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life oh
well I corrected a botched circumcision
from many years ago Oh in terms of plugs